trop de gros naze sinon ta semaine
active
jeudi il a reçu un coup de fil enfin ça
va c'était une erreur
ainsi ils ont essayé de jouer la partie
côté mais alors strike les premiers
coups à dégager des doigts comme un
grave problème la sonorisation enfin
c'est pas la peine d'essayer d'appeler
le syndic
on n'est pas dans le même immeuble se
sauveront n'est même pas dans le même
arrondissement
il ya forcément un moyen de s'arranger
mais c'est pas la peine de vous
installer un bon 4 avant d'avoir des
balles et vos cartons
tube arrêté
c'est ridicule
vous croyez m'avoir comme ça
je pas particulièrement à l'aise en
société
n'empêche que c'est fou et quelques
légendes
ils peuvent je crois que j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un non vous êtes commandes grande
event et vous devez les yeux foncés de
type méditerranéen et cheveux un peu en
bulle et je suis ici avec 34 bonsoir
charlot qui parle
bah oui vous dire une chose c'est qu'on
soit mieux sans voir cette phrase n'a
aucun sens